think about this there was a story that
came up a week or two ago though it
hasn't come up recently because it
didn't support the left-wing narrative
there's about a 24 year old black man
who was found hanging from a tree in
Southern California and the LA Sheriff's
Office said that this guy died from
suicide and all of the BLM rioters the
leadership suggested that this was a
lynching BLM the the self-described
Marxists of BLM and the the crazed
leftists who support them are convinced
that lynchings happen in the US all the
time
it's practically 1875 Alabama or South
Carolina right now in Southern
California all all around the country
they're all these lynchings any normal
person who saw that story realized this
guy died by suicide didn't worry about
it but they pushed and they pushed and
they push now we found out they finally
admitted it yesterday there was no foul
play it was a suicide well what else do
we know about this guy's history we know
he had a history of mental illness we
know that there were prior reports of
suicidal ideation we know he had
disclosed a plan to kill himself prior
to his death all according to the
sheriff's commander Chris marks at a
news conference we know that he
purchased from a local Dollar Tree a red
rope consistent with the one used in the
hanging very sad story that this guy
killed himself there was never any
evidence whatsoever that it was a
lynching but the left insists on pushing
that narrative why so that it could
further divide people so that it could
so that it could encourage the riots
which the scientific establishment was
more than happy to encourage because it
was advancing their political agenda you
remember that letter where they said
they sent out the letter it was over a
thousand public health scientists and
they probably call the experts
quote-unquote and they said that if you
protest the lockdowns that's bad it's
going to kill people and if you protest
for a BLM or any other leftist cause
that's good that'll actually suppress
the spread of the virus
[Music]
[Music]
this video is sponsored by blink sale
the revolutionary invoicing software for
contractors and small businesses spend
less time billing and more time making
bank with blink sale get a free trial at
the link in the video description